[Music]
you know what brain freeze is don't you
here we go it's when you sip something
so cold so
it permeates the roof of your mouth and
freezes the synapses in your brain
so your memories are literally frozen in
place
this is not literally or even
figuratively true brain freeze
or a cold stimulus headache has nothing
to do with memory and everything to do
with the pain receptors being exposed to
extreme swings in temperature
i understand that folky here is using
brain freeze as a metaphor for what
she's doing to poor hunter c20 here but
if you're going for a metaphor why not
use deja vu
now why did i come into the kitchen
again okay ask
how many people are guarding the
timekeepers i'm sorry what
see if you'd gone with deja vu this
might have worked this futuristic
grocery store has security cameras that
track plot related people through the
parking lot
amazing total bull but amazing
which is more of a sin the sudden
inconvenient timing of folky's time door
or that she's more interested in a top
bun rather than concealing herself with
her hood as she has been doing before
her reveal last episode
oh you're right it's both
you do realize that there are other
available options on the spectrum
between incapacitation through magical
means and
murder by disintegration just a thought
but why not carry the very important
weapon with you if you know your powers
won't work
why is no one picking up the whoosh away
rod
i'm all for the bad guy killing the good
guys but come on did
no one train to use these light up
sticks
she had a sword the whole time you're in
my way
only because you walked away from the
elevators which was a really odd choice
given the situation
but now i see you lack vision well
technically this whole show lacks vision
wait was that even meant to be tim and
i'm so used to marvel pummeling my
little fan person brain with easter eggs
that i have no idea if this is supposed
to be a reference to the vision or not
10 cents for once again making me
question the very fabric of my reality
i'm sorry but this is not the even
standoff it's framed to be
sylvie has a sword while loki has a fist
two-fist at most
goodbye variant much more on design this
device
my phone leaves me in a state of low
battery panic for at least three anxiety
riddle
hours before it finally dies and i'm not
depending on it for
any form of chronometric escapism also
shouldn't this device give you plenty of
notice before it runs out of juice
or better yet prevent you from making an
outbound trip to
whenever the if it doesn't have enough
power to get you back home
being stranded some win in a timeline
you're supposed to be protecting seems
like a
guaranteed way to make sure your parents
never get together at the enchantment
under the sea dance
well with a name like that you're just
asking for an apocalyptic event
of all of the apocalypse
that the point wasn't the whole idea of
hiding in apocalypses because there
wouldn't be any survivors and therefore
no chance of her creating any
disturbances in the
time force or whatever it is is silvie
saying that she has apocalypses saved in
there that do
have survivors that makes none of the
sense i suppose now is a good time to
point out that these two untrusting foes
were trying to kill each other a few
moments ago and suddenly our loki is
totally fine with foki getting this
close and touching his face without
any struggle fine what exactly is
causing loki's daggers to make this
shining sound it's not like he's
unsheathing them doesn't he just make
them disappear and then reappear
i suppose he could be using a minor
illusion spell but that seems a bit
cantroopy for loki
i don't know a truce sea of warp i can
get on board with but not a shing
the plan you interrupted was years in
the making
years was it i mean how has sylvie been
able to measure that and if that tornado
in oklahoma was her base of operations
how is she able to spend years there
without i don't know
bumping into herself there's power
somewhere on this moon
we just need enough of it to travel
through interdimensional time and space
where the hell are you going to find
1.21 gigawatts at this hour
just because i have to work with you
doesn't mean i want to hear your voice
tv sends writers when i ask them for
feedback on my narration
so let's talk about the villains playing
your years in the making plan was to
tear the place down
create the ultimate power vacuum and
then just walk away uh
thanks loki you'd be great at tv since
but i swear to odin if you interrupt me
one more time
i'm just checking the coupling making
sure it can connect the pain apple
deliberately puts its users through
every damn
day there's a reason their logo is an
apple with a bite out of it here's a
confusing part of the story where loki
and foki go into a tiny house to find a
massive power source
brute force is no substitute for
diplomacy and guile
it's been a long time this is what you
call diplomacy i guess the asgardian
definition strays far more into the
manipulative [ __ ] variation
hello dear patrice
i know how the disguise spell works and
sure he may look like patrice on the
outside
but there's no way to nail the voice
unless you have the actor feed and have
heard it before
this must be the calmest apocalypse to
have ever apocalypsed is it too much to
ask for a bit of looting or at least an
unruly mob
also i'm calling shenanigans that
anything resembling an orderly line
would be maintained here this is the end
of the
world people don't wait in line like
this for disneyland let alone their only
possible salvation from the coming
apocalypse
also also no one seems to give a damn
that loki and sylvia are just strolling
past cutting to the front of the line
okay there's a couple of withering
stairs but damn it i want my unruly mob
we're doing this one my way
no one behind them sees this what is in
the water here this must be the most
placid group of people in the multiverse
did the whole of canada just move to
this moon how do i look
like someone with a dead plan loki would
be sylvia tv sins
has the train left all those people
behind forgive me if this sounds naive
but surely in a global emergency like
this
the goal is to evacuate as many people
as possible there's so much room left in
this card alone
why is no one bothered by the end of the
world are you sure she was your mother
uh no she's not actually i was adopted
it's a bit of a spoiler for you sorry
about that
no i knew i was adopted what they told
you
so is silly from an alternate timeline
entirely where she chooses to be a woman
and barely remembers her mother or is
she from an alternate dimension where
everything is different
i don't care which turns out to be true
but why the secrecy surely i can't be
expected to root for either of these
mass murderers whatever their origins
but she told me that one day i'd be able
to do it too because
because i could do anything parents who
tell their kids this lie
is there a lucky bow waiting for you at
the end of this crusade
movie has time for this or tv show
acting as though it has the run time of
a movie has time for this
so on the subject of love
to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
postman
whilst running across time a post man
when does he just install
posts for a living oh she means a
mailman
oh he's silly brits what he just
delivers posts all day
suppose next you're gonna tell me works
at the post oh
must have been would be princesses
or perhaps another prince a bit of both
i suspect the same as you the way
lucky's sexuality is revealed here with
zero fanfare just as if it's another
part of his personality is fantastic
still a long way to go but this is a
start you relax your way
and i'll relax mine but why relax at all
why not attempt to drain the power
source for the train at least
once before a nap it is super nice for
the apocalypse to leave the train track
and power sources completely alone as
they traverse towards their destiny
i am all for using headbands as weaponry
but really only as a backup plan to the
sword
well we assume the sword works we
haven't seen it slay anyone so far
also there's no way foki's horned tierra
wouldn't snag part of this ridiculously
knitted getup let alone any of the
pointy weapons used in this fight
come to think of it their uniform should
be riddled with snags runs in the one
wayward string that you can't help but
pull
in fact unravel should be playing in the
background as this
knitted bull shirtery wheezes on she
punches a helmet
he punches a helmet and really what are
helmets for anymore
being thrown through a train window
before your intended stop after drinking
too much alcohol
or predestination station defenestration
post intoxication
if you will so does loki's
magic just make things invisible i was
expecting some sort of extra planar
pocket dimension arrangement
but the temp pad must still physically
exist or would have been destroyed by
the fall
this also means loki's daggers are
currently albeit invisibly piercing any
number of his internal organs
and god knows where he's been shoving
the invisible tesseract all along
oh the mission the mission what your
glorious purpose uh does anyone have the
commercials for episode one
yeah cool roll them did the
screen make you feel better loki
survives this
what about the ark the ark never leaves
because it's destroyed
whoa nelly let me just grab my tin pad
[Music]
where is everyone the ark
the evacuation vessel something like
that would have enough juice to repower
the tempo
see back at this lady's house silvie
doesn't seem to have a clue what the ark
is
so how does she now suddenly know its
history and that it didn't make it off
the planet and if she did know about it
why didn't she take them there to start
with
looks like somebody caught a bout of the
brain freeze you know
i don't think i've ever walked this much
in my life
i'm strolling on the moon
it's gone a blow up soon
what a glorious purpose
oh my god people where is your urgency
you're about to be hit with a planet
you want to know how enchantment works i
have to make physical contact
and then grab hold of their mind
oh how does loki not understand how
enchantment works
especially this loki from 2012 who
literally use this exact power or
something extremely similar to control
the minds of hawkeye dr selvig and half
of sahel
just days earlier i have to make
physical contact
and then grab hold of their mind which
is incredibly confusing considering we
don't always see folky touch the person
herself but we have seen the enchanted
person grab hold of her next victim and
transfer mental ownership powers
so how does this work exactly
i've never actually walked for 10
minutes but given the distance i'm
pretty confident if the ark is launching
in that time our pair of keys is
because this is going to suck do
yourself a favor and believe sylvia here
because the next 10 minutes is just a
whole lot of suck
sure it looks like a lot of things are
happening but believe me when i say that
hiding in these spins power walks
running fighting and ducking
nothing is actually happening
okay mister that's a surefire way to get
yourself expelled from the rickon stark
school of running away from things
you've been warned this is an
apocalyptic event report of an airplane
hijacking and bomb threat with zero
fatalities which
doesn't seem all that apocalyptic does
it between one minute of previous lease
35 seconds of marvel logoing 20 seconds
of loki title carding and 4 minutes and
48 seconds of
end credits we're left with only 33
minutes of content
some bastard is robbing me of over seven
minutes of tom hiddleston and i will not
stand for it
why do you think i blew up your condo
i remember sorry half an hour ago i was
a white head scotsman
oh i know you did send me back to the
future but i'm back
i'm back from the future not so fast
you're in my way you are my way i'll do
you want better
why is gamora i'm the doctor by the way
what's your name
rose nice to meet you rose run for your
life
you're not traveled were you sent here
by the devil
no good sir i'm on the level brute force
is no substitute for diplomacy
and guile
diplomatic community i'm thinking you
want him independence
and i'm thinking you weren't burdened
with an overabundance of schooling